today we're talking about life after
divorce so I'm gonna ask a question
is it fair
that a woman can cheat on a man
take his house
take his cars take his children
and then dictate to that man when and
where he can see or cannot see his
children is that a fair system no
I don't I don't think so if she if she
did the cheating she has no room to say
nothing
and if she did the cheating and she left
she chose she chose to cheat and she
chose to leave so why would you as
you're not going to get a prize for
losing essentially and it's like you
can't dictate what someone does when you
you chose
but they do get rewarded don't they they
do unfortunately seems like a super Fair
system just so fair so fair ladies is
that fair system
Agnes
it was a very personal kind of thing you
know it's like again like it's a
materialistic thing so when we're
looking from this perspective what do we
have even in life you know it's not in
kawas and we're not really own anything
you know
in this situation I don't know what
happened between them two like she
cheated clearly maybe man was like super
awesome man and he was like super
awesome man then it's sad for the man
that has happened to him you know but
then again like you know everybody kind
of plays some certain part even that
cheating happened why did it happen well
at four still it didn't fall so whatever
with that man didn't give whatever she
wanted actually he had the house he had
money had everything
enough you know but then again that's a
different map and it's a personal you
know
but regardless of what happened do you
think he deserves to I don't think
anybody deserves to be out cheated how
treated or how done any kind of way you
know
so now I don't think so
what'd you think
um
she just wanted the house you wanted the
kids she wanted everything for herself
she didn't want any man anymore
basically
it's like a cheat code crazy yeah it's
crazy but that's the system we currently
live on we currently live under whereas
um a woman can actually do all of that
and still be rewarded for it
sorry to worry about that this was like
proof like they went to court or
something yeah that yeah gone to court
you know he can she can take his
finances she can take his children she
can take his house wait hold on pause um
I'm pretty sure if she cheats no
um right now in the UK there's something
called no fault divorce have you ever no
fault division so no fault diverse
divorce means somebody can um they can
apply or or apply for a divorce
and it can be quote unquote no one's
fault wow
um historic historically women have
always had the upper hand in being award
to awarded child custody statistics show
that women win child custody rights
staggeringly 90 of the time yeah so yeah
you can cheat and then do no fault
divorce and say it's no one's fault and
you can supply for a divorce and it can
be no one's fault and you can still get
all of that stuff
do you know do you know what I'm
thinking about yeah no not even that
yeah forget that you know if you look at
it the other way around like would if he
was in a marriage yeah and you got
divorced and the court gave you the the
kids the house which is probably my car
alimony would you even like want to take
it or like
um yeah because at the end of the day
she violated me and you're leaving our
situation and the fact that I'm not that
person to go to court so if we go to
court it was because of her so if I won
of course yeah I'm gonna take all of
that no so you're saying so you're
saying the woman's right to take it then
no she ain't right no I just she the one
that did the cheat and you can't leave
if I'd done a cheating then you know
what by all means it is I messed up
right it doesn't matter who cheated
because if the man cheated and she she
leaves she could leave if she cheated
she could leave but it doesn't matter
and seeing the marriage it's not even
just that same the fact that one cheats
and then the other one leaves you're
breaking up the home
so regardless
yeah but if you're breaking up the home
should you be the one that's getting
everything
no and open in no fairness now I don't
believe so but what if the
it's a is that good
a weird situation if the Man Cheats but
he has everything
is he supposed to give everything to the
woman because he cheats and he decides
to leave and that's all yeah because
that's his his well a lot of the time
even when the man cheats he still gets a
lot of his stuff taken away anyway so
like he gets well and what they don't
talk about is that one in four marriages
are sexless so it's like if you're yeah
one in four so if you're if you're
starving your man of sex and he goes and
gets it elsewhere that's your own damn
fault I swear to God I don't feel bad
for you if you get cheated on no that's
an agenda if you're not if you're not
sleeping with your husband and and he
cheats on you like that is your own
goddamn fault I swear to God and some
other girl says you know what I'm gonna
do it she's not but yeah
no but what's the um
what what's the like price like in terms
of like the types of people that are
getting married so like like in terms of
their the monies that they make
like oh is it generally you mean yeah
like in like statistically like would it
be more um I think rich people get
married right because rich people right
so if we're talking about rich people
afford a wedding exactly
so if the girls the girl should be
working anyway she's independent so
assuming she's independent but you know
we live in the equal Society right now
she should be working as well
do we live in an equal Society
assuming we live in an equal Society
yeah yeah
but inverted commas you know
I'm just saying the way that it's
structured right now
she's supposed to be working
so if she's working and she leaves
how are you going to be able to say the
same thing that you were saying back in
the day before like because you're gonna
say so her excuse for taking the kids
before was oh he's working all the time
he's not gonna have time to look after
the kids but she's working now so she
has to work double time now just be able
to make it well when it comes to I
looked up the reasons that women and men
file for a divorce
um and one this is and there's some
articles that are it's kind of like I'm
not sure like some of them kind of
switch but one is a couple stopped
loving you this is for women the couple
stopped loving each other does that
sound more like women or men
um being bad with money yeah
um the other party having personal
problems lack of love and affection for
men the top four is infidelity lack of
appreciation lack of affection and lack
of commitment that's what it says and we
already know that in the UK 64 of
um divorces are initiated by women in
the U.S since 17 64 in the US is 70 to
even 90 if you're College if you're a
college college educated no but I'm
saying that that's bringing back to my
point so I'm saying then since the
incentivize to do it yeah so can you
really blame someone for being sensitive
like if you told me just marry this girl
and in a year's time you could just
divorce her and take all everything
she's uh take all her things and then
the system's done for you to do that I
would go and do it do you know what I
mean so I don't think that
you know if you told me there's a
million pounds inside of the the truck
I'm gonna go get you know I mean it's
like you're giving me a reason I mean I
blame you if you care more about
finances than your children if you want
to put your kid at every statistical
disadvantage you could ever put a kid at
just for a bag man or woman I judge you
for that no but that's selfish no no
you're missing the point these single
single mothers are not single what do
you mean they got man bro
I was gonna say that you see when women
initiate divorces do you think their
initiating divorce is to be alone
one thing about God they always have a
backup so if she's she's in a whole
marriage you're leaving to go to where
you already had your pillow you're not
the type of person that obviously can
can support without a pillow so where's
your next pillar comment even if it
comes every now and then you need that
pillow which means you add someone on
the side you're back Upland and what
tends to happen as well is those sidemen
don't really want a wife you like how
your husband was wife in you so now like
after the little fling happened and you
get bored now and like it's not going as
how it should be you're now thinking in
your head where I'm I'm alone now so
that's that's the single moment yeah
yeah you you made some incorrect
decisions you know what's interesting um
men are more likely to say that they
want to get married again than women why
do you think that is
um I think that's because men want a
legacy they they want a legacy to show I
think men I can speak for my own
personal experience there is a
there's a pride in men when people say
oh if you've got partner yet this is my
wife this is my children look what I
done look at look at my legacy look at
my kingdom there's that um there's that
pride in men more so I think that there
is in in the modern day women nowadays
that's what I think also there's a lot
of Sims
I understand there's like there's a lot
of guys like that's their way to lock
down a girl
did you get
to offer marriage yeah that's like
that's the only way I can keep her to
lock her down oh man I have to marry her
would you get married
but that's religiously he said he's
gonna have multiple wives
That's religiously you know what I'm
saying like I want to be in heaven with
my wife isn't it
so so
given the current system that I said
like you would get married under this
marriage system
knowing that you could lose everything I
want to lose everything I said knowing
that you could lose everything I could I
couldn't lose everything every man could
deny it's impossible really why because
I'll I'll have more than one
yeah
no but imagine both of them divorce you
and take your money then there will be
another lineup you know I'm saying we
make money over here at me so
it take off and then let's see what you
do have you ever heard stories about
what people when they got the lottery do
the money bro
you give some of these girls a million
pounds and they'll go broke in a year
man come on bro let's get real now yeah
but that's easy to say now when you're
young I mean imagine you get divorced at
60. oh a lot of guys commit suicide
after divorce because they have to start
over and they have no energy to do it
men are five times more likely after a
divorce to commit suicide than women are
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible